tonight we're learning more about how
this is affecting us here locally jeremy
j ford joins us live in the newsroom
after speaking with a newly formed
abortion fund right here in the valley
jeremy
yeah thanks well right here in nevada
our state law ensures abortions can't be
performed within the first 24 weeks of
pregnancy today i spoke with a
representative of wild west access fund
of nevada and they say more and more
people will be heading here to seek
access for abortion
women do not have equal protection under
our constitution each state can now
devise its own abortion law and utah has
immediately banned abortions putting its
trigger law in effect wild west access
fund board president macy haverda says
banned abortions in neighboring states
will have a direct effect on nevada we
here in nevada may see people coming
from out of state to access their care
we have seen people in the past coming
from texas in particular but other
states as well we definitely anticipate
seeing the number of people that check
the out of state but she says having
more people rush in for abortion
services will put a strain in our health
care system now it will take longer to
schedule an appointment and with
abortion time is really of the essence
so anything under 10 weeks is usually
relatively cheap relatively fast but
once it starts getting after that
it's more expensive more time intensive
now although we won't see much of a
change on how abortions are administered
here in nevada it's possible the already
high cost of the procedure could go up
in the newsroom jeremy j ford is live
local now